[Music]
hey all you cool cats and kittens honey
director rocking a little bit of a curly
hair look beautiful kitten head today
keeping you on your toes okay I'm Lauren
and Zima here with Denny D this is eg
live at home where we are bringing you
the entertainment news you need to
escape for a minute in the middle of
this horrible global pandemic first off
Ina Garten helping us escape big time
with a big old drink we're gonna get
into that and then Shaq going off DJing
for his fam in his kitchen during the
quarantine then
oh I spoke to some of the most major
faces in the murder mayhem madness story
that is Tiger King we have exclusives
with Jeff Lowe Joe exotics business
partner and DA Cantrell his mentor to
anyone else we got meanwhile there are
some celeb couples who are struggling a
bit being self isolated with their
partner at such close proximity we're
talking Gwyneth Paltrow and her husband
Brad Falchuk Kristen Bell and Dax
Shepard Kristen talked exclusively to e
t--'s Kevin Frazier meanwhile I spoke
with former mom Jay Shetty who has some
advice for all those couples who are
courting teen together but first um
let's start with my raising a quarantine
e to our girl
ina garden I mean she really gets us in
these trying times we need to cocktail
more than ever
yes daddy drink it up ina making the
world's biggest cosmopolitan in the
world's biggest pandemic of all of our
lifetimes the cooking at home lifestyle
goddess took to Instagram and what's so
great about this video that she posted
it has everybody obsessing over it is
and first she's kind of looking like
she's just making a normal Cosmo right
she's telling me the recipe then you
realize me and she's really using that's
like how big it's a lot of vodka oh
that's a big shaker she's shaking it all
in and then at the end I know whips out
the biggest martini glass we've ever
seen and drinks the whole thing Jenny I
see you tried you try I don't have a big
one wish I needed I had to though Oh
all right I know we're pulling up for
you girl the best part about that was
how unexpected it was cuz you're right
you're not affected but I was I'm
frustrated because I have a huge
wineglass
it's just at work and so I can't get to
it but I ordered off Amazon it's it's
both Cheers
and coffee Cheers oh I get it oh she's a
damn mood though that really put me in
the right spot today
well ina has inspired me to look around
just for what I can find that's what
quarantine E is all about I'm gonna be
making my drinks on this from come on
like anything alcoholic what I want to
tout about it is that it's Tupperware so
you know yeah you might not be able to
have friends over but you're gonna save
your drink for as long as you can and
enjoy it
and the time of a pandemic you can't
share either so that's all you girl okay
gram video you could make this if a
friend stops over oh wait no once no no
it's coming over I love it what a mood
someone else is having a lot of fun in
the kitchen during quarantine Shaquille
O'Neal he turned it all the way up
busted out his turntables and turned it
out in the kitchen
with his kids piccolo
[Music]
you guys you forget shot moonlights as a
DJ DJ diesel is an actual thing really
yes he has performed at festivals and
you know what when you're stuck at home
with your teenagers that's what you
gotta do okay I kind of wish she had
like a a disco light you know - really
sure - get him some yes and pyrotechnics
it was amazing it is it was so much fun
to watch because again we keep saying
this is silver lining about all this I
think is seeing families enjoy their
time together we might get annoyed with
each other which we'll be getting into
later in this episode but I just love
those little moments of laughing with
each other of finding a way to have fun
at home and also to see men that large
especially Shaq jump like that there's
something about it it feels like it the
chaotic energy is on point cuz you're
like this man is the biggest thing he's
just going oh there was that one video
on camera which festival it was it's one
where he did play well he went to go see
other DJ set and you could see him I
mean what is he almost like seven feet
in the crowd like moshing with everybody
like you know turn up a dance party
especially high seven one another one
he's seven feet I'm not to be outdone so
he is performing and performing hahaha
he's dancing in the kitchen with his
sons his stepson and his nephew and
they're all large so that's how you do
it you guys when we've been ordered to
stay at home okay that's how you do it
meanwhile well he's turning it up he's
also going off I don't know if you
caught his podcast yesterday but Shaq on
his podcast the big podcast with Shaq on
Wednesday kind of um reacted very
strongly to those who were criticizing
his like very brief appearance in the
tiger King let's play a clip of it
further than dissect every now and then
I'll do human stuff and get in trouble
whatever ever showed you that I would
hire my animal you know
a man can't go to a zoo right now they
take a picture one day you have to know
about the shackle near John a VHD me say
no to a picture now
b-dawg if you ever see me say no to a
picture now Rob have you ever seen me
say no to a picture no just cuz I take a
picture with you don't mean you're my
friend buddy just take good just cuz I
take a picture with you and say
something for your little video your
podcast don't mean I'm down with you
don't may not do the stuff that you do
you know what I do the right thing I
mean I don't blame it first of all I did
I'm another shot shot but there was only
there's so much more stuff going on in
that docu-series that I cared more about
that in Shaquille O'Neal being in it but
apparently he's been being dragged a
little bit online with a lot of people
connecting him to Joe exotic you know
and so I can spray I mean look I feel
like if you saw the episode it seemed
really clear to me that Shaq stopped by
for some kind of visit to the zoo and he
was just kind of being nice to Joe I
don't think they were friends who were
chatting all this time or anything I
didn't get that impression um but you
know what's hard about this is that look
at the end of the day it's not illegal
for cats to be in zoos for exotic cats
to be in zoos I think what we're getting
into with some of this backlash is
people who do feel really passionately
about whether big animals should be in
cages and and at zoos and the the size
of space they should have to roam and
all that but at the end of the day like
you know this is not overall an illegal
thing and Shaq was going to a zoo you
know I was gonna see it's important to
note that like Shaq has denied any
involvement with Joe exotic Ramon
visiting the zoo and taking some photos
and he even said might take a photo with
the fan that doesn't mean I'm your
friend and I have to agree with them but
you know he also has people from the
actual documentary defending him to you
just spoke with Geoff love yes so oh my
gosh my day yesterday I'm wearing my cat
print earrings was just I was affected
by it I was affected by it because I did
back-to-back interviews with Doc antal
and Jeff Lowe we're gonna talk Jeff Lowe
first he of course is Joe exotics one
time
business partner who Joe has now made
some claims about in a new lawsuit of
his from prison and I talked to Jeff low
and Lauren low about so much let's take
a quick listen he's a sweet man and
impedin eads to leave him alone because
I don't think Shaq cares with Peter
things a common read there is that it
seems maybe these filmmakers weren't
we're telling you different stories
according to you guys or yeah you are
that's a whole nother interview if you
want to get into the nuts and bolts of
that they mislead all of us they paid
everybody for interviews that I know but
maybe didn't hey everybody but they paid
everybody that we know the employees
here all got paid for their interviews
and and they lied to us and they
condescend to taken them to strip clubs
so they could get footage that was
better they gave alcohol to employees
that there were alcoholics to get better
interviews and you know it's just as sad
that they couldn't just come to us and
say here's what we want to do
are you already hooking up with the
nanny you we saw you see I hired
somebody who looks great and who's nice
to look at so you got it you got a ask
the question you know you're a lucky guy
is what you're saying I am a lucky guy
so the nanny I know everybody remembers
the nanny in the docu-series Jeff is
seen literally looking at pictures of
the nanny they plan to hire and he says
well I want to hire someone who looks
good okay so they told me the nanny is
spending time on and off with the baby
right now getting to know the baby
before the day plan to move to where
their new zoo is gonna be but I spoke to
them from the zoo that was once Joe
exotics the great Irwin he would a zoo
so they're there they live on this you
could hear tigers and lions roaring in
the background sometimes during our
interview yeah um yeah Jeff said look
Shaq's a good guy and he didn't have
anything to do with any of this and he
said PETA leave him alone um and he
talked about I mean I pushed him on the
big stuff
look people say you framed Joe exotic
did you people say that you were part of
a plot to kill Carol were
you he addressed all those things and I
think all we can do is ask these people
these questions and and see what their
answers are and and kind of draw our own
conclusions because what captivates me
about Tiger King is there are no
necessary here necessarily hero people
there are no you know for sure
through and through villains like
everybody has a past and everybody has
questions surrounding them one man who
knows all about the ins and outs of the
industry though is doc Ansel when I sat
down with him it was a very different
vibe than Jeff low-doc Hansel gave me
the impression he's a really intelligent
man I mean I asked him multi-part
questions and usually when you're
interviewing someone especially if
they're new to it you know they they
might say wait what was the question
again or go back doc was on it he
answered everything I asked him and as
he said he's been in Hollywood for
decades and decades I mean he made
movies like Ace Ventura he said he
worked on dr. Dolittle he was on
Letterman and Leno back from the day
with his animals and of course that
Britney Spears performance take a look
at what some of what doc Ansel had to
say so that's you that's you in those
photos that's 20 years ago or something
that's right before 9/11 before 9/11 at
the Metropolitan Opera House in New York
City how much did you interact with
Britney she was on top of her game at
that point in her career she was such a
darling just totally just a fanatic
person wanting a perfect performance we
were there for several days rehearsing
so that the Tigers were being relaxed
and happy to be out there and that
everything to be smooth and taken care
of as best as possible she was there
rehearsing and working just the
hardest-working sweetest young girl out
there making all the pieces click
together
I think Carole killed her husband but I
don't know how she did it I only have
the evidence of the show which seemed to
produce a preponderance of ideas it
convinced me that that's probably would
happen so who do you think was
misrepresented the most me barrel killed
her husband and Joe is a crazy guy they
were both portrayed that way that that's
genuinely who they act like anyway we
are not as
characters we are not we have nothing to
do with there being any threat to Cubs
with any raid anything wrong with the
law any notion that there's a cult here
or that women are not large and in
charge here and able to make all the
choices they want you know I live for
the Brittany tea because when I first
saw that photo of him standing in that
cage with a tiger and Brittany clearly
in her iconic like I'm asleep for you
costume for the VMA performance I was
like I need the backstory on this and
you know we stand for it and it sounds
like he did too well he used the
Brittany performance to make such an
interesting point about the documentary
he said look I'm a businessman he said
my Zoo is the ritz-carlton of zoos and
it's because I've made so much money
through this career in part because of
Hollywood he said that he thinks he
remembers charging 38,000 dollars to
bring that Tiger for Britney's
performance so he pointed out why would
I be in this docu-series that I was not
paid for in any way if I'm the type of
person who charges for my time he said
the filmmakers told him it was going to
be a conservation documentary likely
intended for HBO very interesting that
is a claim I feel like that is coming
from a lot of the key players in that
documentary including Caryl Baskin who I
seriously doubt that filmmakers were
convincing her to open up about her
missing husband her current husband the
lawsuit unless it was for the good of
like big saving big cats you don't mean
for anybody out there I just would think
to myself if I have this scandal in my
past that it was not a new scandal for
her when the filmmakers came along
people had been suspicious of her the
authorities had allegedly you know
questioned her on her husband's
disappearance why would you just talk
about something like that for that is
already problematic for you unless you
were doing it for a reason that
compelled you so it is interesting to me
a that Jeff Lowe da canceled both told
me different things that the filmmakers
told them about why the whole thing was
being made and yeah doc cantle making
that point I mean he said
to him they went and shot more footage
in Sumatra with him that he really
thought they were making this
conservation film and he even said that
the footage they did take was used wrong
that scene where he's pointing out his
girlfriend's houses he said according to
him
those are his neighbor's houses he
doesn't even own them and the filmmakers
are and his neighbors were texting him
asking why is my listen that is wall so
is he seeking legal action are either of
them Jeff or Doc kind of seeking legal
action on the filmmakers or Netflix Jeff
didn't seem to be though he did say he
would not be interested in participating
in a season two though Jeff did say
there's so much more footage that they
shot they didn't show he said he feels
they could make a whole other season out
of all this and Doc said his he is only
communicating with the director through
lawyers at this point he would not 100%
say yes he's going to sue but he
certainly said he has his lawyers
looking into what what his options are
from here it really was so fascinating
and look what's also we have to look at
these people through the lens to of
their showman they're they're
entertainers they of course they have
their side of the story that they want
you to believe so I really tried to
grill him and push them all but it is
interesting to think of you know the
filmmakers as part of this story too and
how did it all end up versus how they
started it to be in the first place um
one thing the DA can plunge a flow both
agreed on and DA cantle said this
several times without me even asking him
they both say that they think Carol
Baskin killed her husband no Carol has
denied it Carol is denied we saw her
deny it in tiger King of course but they
both said that they think that and I
asked doc because I don't know if you
remember there was a part in this series
where it sounded like Joe exotics voice
I think was saying Tigers could eat a
man no problem and then consume the body
and I said doc well you're an expert is
that true that they can do that and he
said yes I mean it's so crazy because
obviously
caryl Baskin has been the biggest threat
to all of their businesses and then this
side story and these allegations come
with Carroll and that's the one thing
that all of these guys can agree on it's
the one thing that I feel like the world
is agreeing on right now I mean it's
gonna be interesting to see how that
plays out I would like a second season
just on that case oh I think there is
something there's still so much more
here but I would I would almost like a
new a new producer director team to come
out and approach it with a fresh set of
eyes I mean doc also pointed out all
those little moments in the series when
he's saying hey why don't you guys film
it this way or do this he said that
these filmmakers didn't really know what
they were doing he said that at one
point he had to ask one of the directors
to stop coming because she kept asking
him so many personal questions and he
was confused because he thought it was
for conservation he just had a lot of
really interesting points so III want to
speak to the filmmakers I know we've
reached out to them for an interview and
they they passed on it so I would like
to talk to them in the meantime there
are there's so much more from these
interviews up at ET online.com and also
tonight on ET so check your local
listings or either all I know is that
our of what I'm hoping wishful thinking
here this is a future American crime
story someone get Ryan Murphy and Brad
fall chuck on the phone immediately I'll
help cast you and check out those
interviews for both who Jeff Lo and Doc
antle's say they want to play them
they're casting choices for themselves
are fascinating well speaking of Brad
Falchuk he and grant pouch oh they're
opening up about their struggles amid
quarantine Lauren Ave popped up on a
YouTube video titled how let me get this
right how do you find intimacy and
uncertain times they kind of sat down
with a sexuality and intimacy expert
because they're struggling I mean
they're among so many other couples who
are cohabitating in this crisis for the
first time within close proximity and
nowhere to go I know you and I can
relate they also talked about how when
it's two teenagers fifteen-year-old
Apple and 13 o Moses they're also cooped
up in the house and everyone's feeling a
little pent up you know what they join a
laundry lists I'm sure of people who are
trying to figure it out Kristen Bell and
Dax Shepard among them Kristen just sat
down with ETS Kevin Frazier about how
your husband acts are kind of driving
each other crazy in quarantine take a
look you have gotten on each other's
last nerve this last couple it's we're
very much better now because we're
laughing about it but we were not
laughing about it for the first couple
days that's the hard spot but yeah where
it's when you're when you realize that
you're I love spending time with him and
he loves spending time with me but I
think what is different about this
quarantine time is you have so much more
time to think about the other person and
their actions and sort of replay what
they said or attach a meaning to
something that they did and like that I
could do without nobody really needs
time for that that's that's useless I
just love how she's keeping it real
because I know a lot a few people can
relay I mean day twenty twenty
consecutive days actually 21 consecutive
days with my boo I'm actually shocked
how well it's going
and we haven't wanted to kill each other
yet yet how long who knows how long that
will last but so far so good how about
you Lauren I have to be honest what sort
of really hard for me to admit is that
is like the word that your relationship
is tested you know because I don't it's
a hard thing to see out loud that you
feel like your relationship is being
tested and also for a reason that none
of us wanted right it's not like we
disagree on something or we have this
fundamental life difference but I do
think that
a global crisis like I do think we've
grown closer I think we've leaned on
each other more I think we learned about
each other more but you certainly have
to adapt and adjust and there is
something about that just saying that
things aren't easy is is almost like a
little bit of a scary thing to say
especially when everything else is so
uncertain right now well no and it's
that too right but that's when it's kind
of special and I don't take for granted
that I have someone here in these on
certain times when like my anxieties at
an all-time high
I am happy alone well exactly and I will
say like and this is a good problem to
have it's like what happens when we get
on the other side of this like we've
become kind of codependent
you know like I'm gonna miss him in my
bed yeah and and you know and then
there's there's those other couples who
are struggling because there's so much
they're spending so much time together
and so I actually got a chance to talk
to Jay Shetty of course he's a former
mom turned he's a host of his own
podcast and he shared this advice with
me for couples who are stuck in
quarantine together one of the things
that me and my wife have really worked
on is defining our spaces in our work
day it's awesome for eight hours of the
majority of the day that you're working
from home that you both still have that
space and time because you're used to it
right you know used to sitting next to
each other every single day the second
thing I'd say is make sure that you
create meaningful things for you to do
together
it's easy right now to think there is no
date night there is no way of having fun
maybe we should just sit here and keep
watching stuff together the whole night
still make an attempt to have a date
night indoors maybe have a virtual date
night with all your friends and do a
couple's night together like find new
ways of still creating special moments
together where it doesn't just feel like
we're doing the same routine that's what
relationship get tricky but you can do
the same thing every single day and so
that's something I would look at so yeah
I mean see it's really important that
even though we're gonna stuck at the
house you still kind of have to treat it
as if it's a workday you know how your
separate spaces it to work and then also
plan those special moments to get
whether it's a I mean you have no choice
it's most likely gonna be a date man at
home but make sure you're still doing
that and also my the the biggest thing I
took away from talking to Jay was like
don't lean on your partner to entertain
you that's not their job so I guess I
guess we have each other Lauren to
entertain it's a good tip it it is and
it's so true and listen if you're in
need of entertaining yourself look no
further than the Getty Museum who
actually tweeted folks to recreate some
classic paintings and while they're in
quarantine and people we're all out it
did not disappoint did you see some of
these I love it because it's like look
one thing that we are kind of missing
right now is art and cultural
experiences in person and the Getty
Museum who expected them to hop on this
but I love that they did this horse made
out of clothes I love the creativity of
course people using blankets and sheets
we've we've got coke cans instead of
teacups for this classic and you know a
public instead of a baby but it works
let's get creative exactly I was about
to say that people are getting so
creative in the time of quarantine and
tick tock is not your cup of tea
I want you recreate a Renaissance
painting do it you have the time I'm
love you thank you for entertaining me
quarantine ease all day is it's not even
five o'clock yet I hope it is were you
guys proud of it that's right until then
we'll see you guys tomorrow
ye
[Music]